So welcome everyone to this toxic Google event.
We're here with Beau Lotto,
who's going to be talking about his new book deviate.
So Bo is a,
he's a world renowned neuroscientist,
entrepreneur and also a two time Ted talk speaker.
And in this book deviate,
he's drawing from over two decades of two decades of research to reveal starling
truths about how we perceive the world and how our brain perceives the world.
So without further ado,
I'm going to leave it to Bo.
Um,
thanks for coming.
It's such a lovely day outside.
Nice to be,
uh,
would have been nice to be out there.
We should do it out there.
Um,
so we're going to talk about perception,
right?
And actually everyone here in some senses is dealing with perception.
And the reason is because perception underpins everything.
You think,
you know,
you believe the clothes you wear,
the people who fall in love with everything because with perception,
so to understand perception is really to understand not just how the brain
works,
which is what I'm interested in of course,
but what it is to be human.
And if you really want to get people to see differently,
we have to understand the principles by how we see in the first place.
All right,
so a key question to perception then,
which we've all been thinking about,
in fact we've been thinking about for thousands of years,
is do we see reality?
So how many here at Google?
Thank you.
See the world as it really is.
Okay.
No,
there's always one.
If you're not seeing the world as it really is,
what do you seeing?
How did you get here if you're not seeing the world accurately?
Sorry.
So I think,
but I'm curious.
I mean I think you all think you see the world accurately.
Why?
Because I think you all believe that illusions exist.
So do you believe in illusion?
Yes.
So an illusion by definition is to see the world differently from the way it
really is.
So if you believe in illusions,
you think that you actually evolve to see the world accurately.
Most of the time it's just that sometimes you get it wrong.
Okay?
So what we can do is do a quick test to see how good you are at seeing the world
accurately.
So how many bears do you see?
Okay,
three.
Only three
did you say?
Oh you don't want to talk to,
okay,
keep looking around.
Look differently.
Right?
Turn your head.
Imagine.
Can you see four
five,
six.
Do I hear six?
It's like an auction.
You,
yeah,
there could be pandas.
It's a bear right there.
11 bears hiding there,
right?
The point is,
the more differently you look at something,
the more things reveal.
But that's actually quite a complex scene.
So we could try something much simpler,
which is much more natural.
So how many can see the Predator that's about to jump out at you?
And if you haven't seen it yet,
you're dead right.
Especially here.
So who thinks they can save the rest of the room?
Where do you think it is?
Right up there at the top.
Okay,
you're dead.
Okay.
Is it okay.
Let's just add 10% of the information.
Cause 90% of the information you're brand new to see actually comes from gray
scale.
So we'll add 10% of the information and can you find it now?
All right,
for those who may be,
you shouldn't be at Google.
There it is.
Okay.
So now if we go back,
you can see it was always staring at you,
right?
It was always there.
And this makes a really important point when it comes to vision,
which is only 10% of the information you can come on in,
which is only 10% of the information your brain uses.
C actually comes from from your eyes.
The other 90% comes from other parts of your brain is your eyes are almost
pointless when it comes to vision,
right?
It's like the keyboard is to a computer.
It's how you get the stuff in.
But it's very little to with at Jax.
You see?
Alright,
so,
but again,
this is still a fairly complex scenes.
Let's try something even simpler,
right?
Which is just lightness.
Surely people that Google can see the world accurately in terms of light
intensity,
right?
Even Jelly fish can see lightness and don't even have a brain,
So surely you can see the world accurately.
And if that's true,
then things that are the same should always look the same.
And things that are different should always look different.
And these two circles are physically the same.
And do they look the same?
Yeah.
All right.
So thank goodness,
at least at this level you can see the world accurately.
But what happens if I don't change those dogs?
I just changed what surrounds them.
What happens to your perception?
Do they still look the same?
No.
The one on the left,
we'll probably look lighter in the one on the right.
Yes.
And this makes it so nothing is actually changing on those circles.
Just your perception of them.
And this is a simplest illusion that your brain has,
which is called simultaneous brightness contrast.
And we really don't know how it works,
but what it demonstrates the most basic level of vision of perception,
which member underpins everything it is to be you.
Context is everything.
Your brain did not actually evolve to do absolutes and evolve to do
relationships.
It's not interested in less.
It's contextual in contrast.
Okay.
So much so that as you're looking at me right now,
your eyes are actually moving.
They're called [inaudible] and Microsoft codes.
And you can stop your eyes from moving by closing one eye,
sticking your finger,
and to the tear duct can pushing back,
right?
You can do at home with your kids or we're friends,
And you're basically pushing your eyeball back into its socket and your eyes
stops moving.
What happens?
Your eyes open and your eyeballs stopped moving.
What do you think happened?
You go blind,
of course you'll go blind if you shove your finger into the back,
right?
But if by just simply stopping,
I for moving,
your brain has nothing interesting to see because it's only interested in change
in space and time.
So if you stop change,
your brain goes blind.
Okay?
So
we've known that context is everything for a very long time.
But if our deeper question is not that context is everything,
but why it is and understand why context is everything is really to understand
what it is to be human,
but also to understand how it is we can help people to see differently.
So I'm going to,
instead of telling you,
I'm going to show you,
and this is actually at the heart of a machine vision of automatic automatic
cars,
et cetera.
This is the fundamental problem that visual systems evolved to salt.
So hold up your finger and see if you can make your finger the same size as me
by lining up your finger with me,
right?
The right finger.
Right?
Can you make us the same size?
Yes.
Okay.
We're not the same size,
right?
This is big,
But as far as your eye is concerned,
we are the same.
It's because data that falls onto your eyes,
into your ears,
onto your skin.
Conflates multiple aspects of the world in this case,
size and distance,
right?
But the only access we have to the world is this is the data that your sense is
the tech,
but the data that your senses detect is completely meaningless.
Right?
Which makes data itself.
So who's working on big data?
We're at Google,
right?
Data is pointless,
It is literally pointless in of itself because it doesn't tell your brain what
to do.
It doesn't come with instructions.
It conflates multiple aspects of the world.
And this is true at the most fundamental level of perception.
It could be allowed being far away or quiet object or clothes,
or a bright object on dark light or a dark object on the bright light,
right?
These different aspects of the world can give rise to more two identical pieces
of data,
but we know have no access to that world.
So how does your brain deal with the fundamental challenge that it is to
survive,
which is uncertainty?
This is the problem that every single brain,
in fact,
every single neural net is adapted to deal with,
which is uncertainty.
Ambiguity.
So what's the other piece of information your brain has to see except for the
data and the moment?
What else does it have?
Access to memory experience.
So the functional structure of your brain is literally a physical manifestation
of its past with the world and not a passive interaction,
but a physical interaction.
Your brain makes meaning by physically interacting with the sources of the
meaningless data and it makes meaning from it.
Okay?
That's how your brain then shapes itself.
It's not a passive receiving of information,
which is why your brain actually evolved to continually redefine normality,
right?
And you see everything relative to that continually changing normal.
So I want to show you how quickly your brain can redefine normality by first
noticing that those two desert scenes are basically the same.
Yes.
One is just a flipping of the other in terms of color.
The same.
I want you to stare at the dock between the red and the green.
Don't look anywhere else,
okay?
We're going to do a bit of a magic trick,
but it's gonna happen inside your head,
okay?
So as you're staring at that dot,
your brain is redefining normality.
It's learning that the less side of it's visual field is under greenlight,
and the right side is under red.
That's becoming this new reality,
right?
You're also getting very sleepy,
Keep looking at that dot.
Don't look anywhere else.
When I tell you to,
I want you to look at the dot between the desert scenes,
but not yet.
Okay?
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Do they still look the same?
No.
The one,
unless you look reddish,
the one on the right should look greenish.
Yes.
And now as you look around,
your brain will continue to redefine a melody again.
Yes.
So that's how quick your brain redefines reality at the most basic level of
lightness.
So when you open your eyes,
what do you see?
You can't see the world as it really is because your brain is forever separate
from that.
You can't see the data or it would be pointless to see the data because it could
mean anything.
So instead what you see in the meaning that was useful to see in the past,
you see what we call the empirical significance of information.
You see the behavioral value of the data,
not the data.
That is literally what you're seeing,
right?
So the reason why your brain adapts is because what was once useful may no
longer be useful.
So your brain is continually redefining normality and seeing things relative to
that changing normal.
So to give you a sense of what I mean by seeing meaning,
we'll do it in the context of language.
So we'll pretend like we're in a classroom.
Okay.
So the next few slides,
I want you to read what you see.
We'll do it altogether.
Okay?
Ready?
One,
two,
three.
Good.
One,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three.
Okay.
One,
two,
three.
What are you reading?
Right?
Remember the instructions I said,
read what you see.
There are no words there.
You all failed,
right?
That literally says why are written right?
There's no law of physics tells you have to put an h between that.
Wna Why do you do so?
Because your brain has encode the statistics of core Korean letters in the
English and other languages.
So when you're presented with a completely arbitrary context of w space agey,
you put an h there because it was useful to do so in the past.
But there's no inherent value in this letter stream.
It's completely arbitrary.
It doesn't exist without us.
And also notice none of you read what you dreaming because I had you reading.
That was your recent history.
So you interpreted this in terms of your recent history.
So you read what you're reading,
right?
And this is true at the most basic level of perception.
So if you think back to lightness,
which again is our simplest perception,
you'll see a dark brown towel at the top and a light orange towel at the side.
Yes.
That is your perceptual reality.
You will split your life that they are different.
Yes.
When in fact they're exactly the same.
Nothing is changing on the screen at all except the meaning of the data you're
seeing,
not the information,
but the meaning of the information based on your history and not just your
history,
the history of your culture and the history of evolutionary ancestors.
Right?
Most of your life happened without you there.
Right.
We come into the world with all kinds of perceptual meetings.
What's true for color is also true for form.
So these two tables are the same.
Agreed.
No.
What's wrong?
No,
the green,
the red table is simply the green table on its side.
They have the exact same dimensions.
The only thing that varies,
or the angles at the corner,
again,
you're seeing the meaning of the data,
not the data.
It would be pointless to see the data.
The data is they have the exact same dimensions but behaviourally that would've
been useful in the past given the context.
Right?
And what's true for color and form is also true for more complex perceptions,
like the combination of light and sound.
So when I play this video,
this is something we worked on for BBC and many years ago and it's called the
McGurk effect.
And so when you,
when I play the sound,
you'll notice he says
spa is an f bomb.
Yes,
Bop bop,
of course.
Right?
And on the right you'll notice he says bar as an a B Bar,
right?
Bar Bar,
Bar bar.
Yes.
Simple.
So when I played them both together,
you'd have far on the left and bar on the right
bar,
Bar,
Bar bar.
Great.
Now close your eyes.
Ah,
bar by many sounds.
Do you hear bar bar,
Bar,
Bar?
There's only ever sound bar.
If you see his lips make the shape of an hour,
you're a far the shape of a beat.
You're a bar bar right bar.
And notice the sounds not even coming from the screen is coming from the
speakers.
Bop Bar Bar,
things changing,
you're seeing the meaning of the data based on the cost.
We could watch it all.
Ba,
right?
Which means that life is actually really quite simple,
Very fundamental,
very basic.
At any point in time,
your brain is only ever making one choice,
right?
One decision at a moment time,
which is do I go towards something or do I go away from something?
Right?
And where do you go towards or away?
The perceptions that you have,
the behaviors or make are simply a reflex grounded in your history.
You have no free will and what you're doing perceiving right now it's just like
when the doctor hits your patellar tendon and your leg goes out,
right?
It is a reflex and that reflex is grounded base on what was useful to do
perceive in the past.
Okay,
so where do you go towards or away is determined by your history,
your culture,
history,
your evolutionary history.
You have very little control in the moment of what you're going to do,
right?
So what you perceive,
the history that you perceive,
okay,
is not what the thing turned out to be.
It's not the data.
It's simply what you perceived before.
So what do you perceive now?
What you do now is what you did before the history of your past perceptions.
Okay?
So I'm going to show you how powerful this is in the context of sound.
I'm going to get you to hear something that originally doesn't even exist,
and it's going to be simply because of your history of having perceived it.
Do I want you to,
if not,
there are no words,
nothing interesting,
Bob Water.
Let's find out.
Let's try this,
right?
Read along and listen.
Did you hear that?
Are you getting better at it?
Hearing it?
Notice you're getting better it hearing something that doesn't actually exist.
You're becoming delusional,
right?
Which is actually the
right,
which is the power and the beautiful thing about the human brain,
right?
We perceive,
we can imagine,
but the point here is that you're perceiving something based on your history of
perceiving it.
And what does this sound?
It's simply this played backwards.
I'm not the one
another one,
right?
Which means that you're like this little guy in a space of possibility.
Your brain can never do big jumps.
I can't get from here to the door without passing through the space between
right at any moment in time you're going to make a choice and your choice is to
go to the next most likely based on your history of experience.
And we could represent this mathematically in terms of a space of possibility,
a search space,
and you can't just teleport yourself around this space.
You can only ever make small steps and you're going to make small steps to
Pyramind by the,
by the dimensionality,
the structure of the space zoom to go to the next most likely possible,
right?
And what determines the structure of this space are your assumptions.
That's what experience gives you.
It gives you your assumptions and biases,
which means that everything you do is grounded in those assumptions.
Not that sometimes you have an assumption,
you always have an assumption.
So it's as if your brain has given us data is completely meaningless.
Arbitrary data,
which is just energy from the world.
And it constructs these present.
There's perceptions and it projects out into the world,
right?
So if a tree falls in the world and no one's there to hear it,
does it make a sound?
The answer is no.
It creates energy,
but it doesn't make a sound because the founders a construct of your brain.
And the same way that this screen is not blue,
these chairs are not white,
right?
That is not read your shirt.
It couldn't be closer to you.
It's actually literally inside your head.
Projected outward,
right?
We color objects,
we color the world.
We are the source of those perceptions.
We color the world.
Color is not a function of the world itself.
And we project these meanings even to under more complex ideas.
So here's an example.
This was a video made in the 1919 mid 1940s and of course,
there's nothing meaningful about these two triangles in this circle until we put
them in motion.
And immediately we start projecting a meaning onto these completely arbitrary
objects,
okay?
We start hating one fear for a full another,
right?
This is basically a horror film,
Watch.
Okay?
You're scared for the circle,
right?
The meanings don't exist on the screen.
Pain is a perfect example.
There's nothing painful in the world.
Painful pain is a useful perception about the world that exists in inside your
head,
right?
And so what's true for color was true for objects is actually true for other
people.
You have no access to the spectral qualities of surfaces,
but nor do you have access to inside what someone's inside someone's head.
You have no access to another person's thought.
People are just the sources of meaningless data,
right?
You are the source of own meaningless data.
You then project meaning onto them.
Every personality you perceive is actually inside you projected outward.
You have no way of determining whether or not your perceptions actually
accurate.
When you connect with someone,
it's because you're perceived meaning of them happens to coincide with their
perceived meaning of themselves.
Okay?
Right?
We color other people.
Okay.
You're a complete group within.
So I'm going to show you how powerful this is just simply in terms of a funny
American football situation where notice how the behavior of the quarterback
completely changes the his perceived meaning by the defense.
Okay?
[inaudible]
you can do that one,
right?
So when it comes to perception,
which underpins everything,
it is to be human.
We are just like this frog.
And I don't mean we're metaphoric.
We'd like this frog.
I mean,
we're literally like this frog.
So this is virtual reality for a frog.
All right?
All right.
Is getting a stimulus and as January,
January behavior,
that was useful in the past,
just like us.
It's like a Black Mirror episode for frog
and he's doing fight.
Well,
right.
We'll go quite her way.
We also get a bit annoyed right now you're probably thinking,
I'm not like a frog.
I've got free will,
right?
They might be frogs.
I'm not a frog.
I forgot.
So we're going to test your fee.
Will we're going to see if I can read everybody's mind in this room,
right?
All at the same time by predicting what name you're going to give to completely
arbitrary shapes.
These are meaningless shapes,
not circles.
Dimes as squares.
They have no name the greed.
Yes.
Okay.
I'm going to give you two completely arbitrary sounds.
When is Kiki and the other is Booboo,
right?
They also don't mean anything.
Now you independent free thinking.
People tell me which of these shapes which has no name is Kiki and which of
these shapes is moving right?
How are you on the right?
Save boob was on the right and Kiki's on the left.
Yes.
How long do you want to say the opposite?
So I read your mind,
right?
Why is this happening?
Why do you tight,
uh,
associate them this way.
It's the shapes.
What is it about the shapes?
It could be the shapes of the letters.
It actually has to do with the sharpness,
right?
It has to do with actually your perception of pain.
Your brain has an overrepresentation of rounded this in sharp myth because it
was behavioral useful to do so.
Right?
And Kiki and booboo are sharp and rounded sounds.
So if I give you the word love and hate,
how many of you say the one on the right is love and the one on the left is
hate?
Yes.
Depending on the state,
you have relationship,
right?
Right.
Because if I give you the word hate and I prick your finger,
I activate the same parts of your brain because hate is actually painful.
It's the behavioral significance of the word that your brain is encoding,
right?
And it's behavioral sickness of those sharp corners,
which is pain,
okay?
This is the basis of metaphor.
You're mapping meanings.
You're not mapping data.
So if this is true of everything that I see is granted in my history and what
that history gives me,
your assumptions and those assumptions are essential for my survival.
Every time I take a step,
my brain has all kinds of assumptions that the floor is not going to give away.
My legs aren't going to avoid.
These are essential for our survival.
But the problem is the world changes.
So what was once useful when they are longer be useful?
So we have to change our assumptions,
right?
And that's the basis for how we see differently.
Change your assumptions and you'll change your perception,
right?
If you're a space of possibility is determined by your assumptions of what lies
right next to me is determined by what I assume to be true by changing what I
assume to be true.
I'll change what Liz right next to me.
Okay.
I'm going to show you how powerful this is simply in the context of perceived
motion.
So as I put this into motion,
you'll see,
probably assume it's spinning from left to right.
Yes.
That's because your brain has the assumption that it looks down onto surfaces.
We come into the world with this assumption,
with this bias in the same way we come into the world,
the assumption that light comes from above.
Okay.
We incorporate the laws of physics into our perception.
Right?
We'll come to that.
Okay.
So,
um,
so for most of you,
the most likely perception given the assumption is because your brain has a
different assumption,
which you're not aware of,
but I'll make it explicit in a second.
Sorry.
But the explicit assumption is that you're actually looking up at the surface,
not down and couldn't be a good way.
Um,
so most of you will assume that your brain is actually looking down to that
surface.
If you're looking down at surface and the most likely perception is left or
right,
the possibility that spinning right to left is actually impossible given that
assumption.
Okay.
But if I put it into motion and you try to play with your assumption,
challenge assumption,
imagine looking up at it instead of down,
it will then go in the opposite direction.
Right?
So sometimes if you blur your eyes,
blink,
you can get it to flip.
So can you get it go the opposite direction or do you have it just going in that
same direction?
Sitting here.
Here?
Yes,
exactly.
Can you get to flip though?
Yeah,
but the reason why it's flipping is can you get us flip who often get it to
flip?
Yeah.
Blur your eyes and blink and look around it.
Okay.
You got it.
What's happening is basically when you assume when your brain has the assumption
that you're looking down onto the surface,
the most likely interpretation is left or right.
Right?
Given that assumption,
as soon as you change that assumption that you're looking up at it,
they'll most likely perception is it spinning the opposite direction from right
to left.
What was previously possible becomes impossible.
You can no longer see it spinning from left to right because you've changed your
perception and every time you switch your perception,
what your brain is doing is changing.
It's assumption whether it's looking up or down because it has a different
meaning.
Depending on that assumption,
while the stimulus might be by stable mathematically it's not by stable in your
head is determined by what assumptions you're making.
All right,
so what was once impossible become possible once possibly becomes impossible.
All you're doing is changing your assumptions and we're just talking about
motion.
This is what creativity is.
Your brain never does.
Big Jumps in other brings to things that are far apart together.
It only ever makes a small step,
right?
But it changes what's next to it.
By changing its search space,
by changing the assumptions that define that search space.
Right?
So a quick question,
which is,
which direction is actually rotating?
How many things left to right,
right to left.
I don't care.
There's no emotion on the screen at all,
right?
There's literally no emotion.
Agreed.
No,
I mean it's an animation,
right?
You're looking at a series of still images that are slightly different from each
other.
Your brain is taking that small change and seeing the meaning of the change,
which we call five motion.
If I took the all those images and put them in random sequence,
you would simply see a flicker.
So you're seeing the meaning of the change,
not the change.
Okay?
So this idea that Trey activity is this chaotic,
messy,
serendipitous process is predicated on the idea that the brain puts two things
that are far apart together,
that it actually jumps teleport within it.
Search space.
That's not how adaptive systems work.
They only ever do small steps.
Okay?
So if that's true,
then in fact there's nothing creative about creativity is only created from the
outside.
When you see someone putting two things that are far apart together is because
for you,
they are far apart together.
You have a different search space for them.
They're making us not as simple.
They're making a logical next step consciously or unconsciously to the next most
likely possible based on their search space,
which is based on their assumptions
because they have different assumptions,
different history.
They have a different search space,
right?
And you think,
wow,
how did they do that?
How do they bring those two things that far apart together?
Again for you,
they are for them,
they're not.
So creativity is this process of taking small steps to next most likely changing
or spas.
Pace of possibility by questioning your assumptions.
Okay?
And that's the basis for how we change our assumptions,
which is all revolutions begin with a joke.
They begin with a question.
Nothing interesting begins with knowing.
It begins with not knowing,
right?
It doesn't begin with an answer.
It begins with a question and it begins with a good question,
right?
You could be a great experiment that's come up with a great experimental design.
But if you're asking a bad question,
who cares?
The cash isn't a good question,
not necessarily in the right answer,
right?
So if you're actually wanting you to get someone to shift from a to B,
the first step is not actually be the first step is just to stop.
The first step is to stop the association that you're making with that stimulus.
The first step is to go to not a
right.
If what I'm doing is I get a stimulus and automatic generate a meaning.
The first step is not to create a new meaning.
The first step is to not make that meaning,
right.
To go to not a,
and then once you're in that space of uncertainty,
now you can go in multiple directions.
So you can control the process of going to not a right,
but you can't control where you go next.
And we'll come to the importance of ecology for where you go next after.
Okay.
But if this is true,
if asking questions and in particular good questions is the basis of creativity,
why is it so difficult to ask a good question?
Right?
Why is that so hard for us?
I'm going to suggest two main reasons for this.
There are others,
but these are two main reasons.
And the first one is that we often walk through life thinking.
We have an objective view of the world,
that we're rational,
right?
That we have no assumptions and biases or will admit that sometimes we do.
It's just that not always,
but the point here is every time you make a resection of behavior,
you have biases and assumptions.
You can never escape from them.
You can change them.
You can never escape from having assumptions and biases,
right?
So here's a game you can play when you have people around for dinner,
And you can do it as a thought experiment right now to demonstrate the
rationality of who we are.
I imagine you have a glass of water.
All right?
And Imagine,
um,
uh,
spitting inside your glass of water.
All right?
So do this at home when you have friends around,
right?
Imagine this,
imagine spitting into your glass of water,
right?
So now imagine drinking it.
Do you get a sense of disgust,
but it's completely irrational,
right?
What was once in your mouth,
you're simply putting right back in,
right?
It's just part of you,
But we can't,
but help generate this perception of disgust,
even though it's completely rational.
No kids would be fine with it.
Even if it was someone else's saliva,
they'd be fine with it,
right?
Right.
So everything you do has a bias.
Everything you do has an assumption,
okay?
But the other problem is that these assumptions are often hidden to us.
We often have no idea why we do what we do.
In the same way,
you didn't know why you necessarily name those two shapes,
Kiki and Booboo,
okay?
Our assumptions are often hidden to us.
And here's an example of one.
So there's nothing Barack Obama could do to prove that he was born here.
Uh,
if there was maybe witnesses that were attendance at his birth,
his mother,
would you listen to his mother?
Now she has motivation to lie.
Do you don't trust a drawn Donald Trump's birth certificate either?
Ah,
yeah.
Because he's been here forever.
How do you know about you?
What's your proof?
Um,
well,
his parents,
and they're biased.
I'm talking about like people who could be the day be biased.
I'm just using your logic against you.
And we laughed.
But we're no different,
right?
Everything we do,
our assumptions,
and we often don't know that we're aware that,
that we're being guided our decisions or choices or being guided by these
assumptions that are almost blind to us,
right?
We're blind to them,
Hence the power of diversity of groups,
right?
So diversity of groups have to see at least two significances.
First of all,
the best person to reveal your own assumptions to you is rarely you.
It's usually someone else and the right kind of environment.
So if you give me two groups,
one average lower Iq from a more diverse background versus another group,
which is higher average Iq,
but from the same background,
I want the first group,
right?
Because in that group and the right setting,
they're more likely to reveal their own assumptions to each other.
What's more,
the search space of that group is much more complex,
right?
It's a higher dimensional search space cause they have more diverse assumptions.
We know from complex systems theory,
the best solutions are more likely to exist in a more complex search space than
in a simpler search space.
As simpler search space is more adaptable,
more evolvable,
right?
But it's actually less likely to hold the best solution.
So I want the first group,
I discovered what my assumptions are and I can occupy within a more complex
search space in the right environment,
which I'll come to you in a moment.
Right?
And the kind of search space and the kind of combination diversity that tend to
work with his expert with naive and the reason because experts are super
efficient,
right?
But they're terrible asking a good question.
But what's ironic is they can recognize a good question when asked.
Whereas people who are naive,
they can ask great questions but they don't know they're great questions.
So we find it's a great combination.
Right?
And also the power of actually stepping into a space,
which is different from what you know.
So you can actually shift yourself from expert and naive back and back and
forth.
So you can occupy both ways of being at the same time.
So both in groups,
but also internally is the combination of expert and I and also think about
technologies obviously here.
So what defines the best technology?
One argument is that it's not what enables us to do what we can already do
faster,
easier with less friction.
Those are good technologies are useful,
but not necessarily transformative.
What are the ones that are transformative?
I'd suggest they make the invisible visible.
They enable us to see what we couldn't see before a microscope or telescope MRI,
even a book,
being able to travel to a new culture,
right?
Because not only does that reveal our own assumptions to ourself and enables us
to expand the complexity of our assumptions.
All right.
The shift from being the center of the universe to then revolving around,
orbiting around the sun completely changed our assumptions of what it was to be
human.
Those are transformative technologies that enable us to see what we couldn't see
previously,
right?
Which is why creativity actually begins with humility.
It begins with not knowing.
Okay?
So actually one of my aims in this talk is that you know less at the end than
you think you know now,
right?
Because nothing interesting begins with knowing.
It begins with not knowing.
So the second one and the most difficult is it might be that you now accept that
you,
everything you do as a bias and assumption and that you're going to now try to
reveal what they are to yourself or through others.
But now you have the next step,
which is to question them.
But we hate not knowing because to question assumption,
especially in assumptions that define who you are puts you into uncertainty.
And we hate uncertainty to not be sure that was a predator.
It's too late.
Your brain evolved to take what is uncertain and to make it certain.
So when you go down below on a boat and your eyes are moving and registered to
vote,
and your eyes are saying,
oh,
we're standing still,
but your inner ears is saying,
no,
we're moving.
And your brain cannot not deal with that conflict,
which is one of the reasons why you get seasick.
So you'd go above deck and you watch her eyes.
So your eyes are interrupters and moving in registered,
right.
We hate uncertainty because dying is easy
to step into.
Uncertainty is literally to not know throughout evolution was to increase the
probability of dying.
Your brain evolved to predict the better stable to brick,
the more likely it is able to survive.
Okay.
And what's more,
the best questions create the most uncertainty.
So for instance,
imagine we were a model,
your biases,
your assumptions as a network,
right?
Which we could do with the gene regulatory network or your biases,
And in the upper left,
those your biases that you're,
that are not connected to each other,
right?
It'd be like a gene that's in coding the color of your eyes.
Okay.
Now,
if we were to question that bias and metaphoric,
we move it.
Nothing else changes just that wild.
Now imagine instead you questioned abayas,
you move a bias,
it's fully connected to all the other assumptions,
what something that may be defines what it is to be you.
That would be an example of say,
a homeobox gene that determines the segmentation of the body,
right?
If you shift that buys the same amount of energy,
same amount of movement,
the whole system shifts,
okay?
This is what we call a complex systems,
a point of self criticality,
and here's an ex,
we experienced this in nature all the time.
Here's an example.
This snow bank is under a tremendous amount of tension because it's fully
connected.
You add a small amount of weight and the whole thing gives way.
All right?
So great questions can cause massive shifts,
right?
And uncertainty,
okay,
and now you're all wondering whether or not he survived.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm not going to fill you just fit,
right,
because you're experiencing uncertainty,
right?
That's what it is.
The answer you want to know.
Right?
We hate not knowing,
right?
And sitting with that moment of not knowing,
and yet the irony is that the only place you can go if you're ever going to be
creative is to step into uncertainty.
And again,
to be uncertainty creates a tremendous amount of stress,
is one of our biggest sources of unwellness in our world,
right?
Is this be an uncertainty,
It actually decreases connectivity with feminine brain decreases adaptability,
increases brain cell death.
It actually makes you a more extreme version of yourself.
If you're liberal and become more liberal.
If you're a conservative,
you become more conservative.
You go to a place that is familiar almost every behavior you do,
you do in order to increase certainty,
right?
You could argue is one of the reasons why Uber was originally successful,
not because they enabled you to order a taxi easier is because they told you
when the taxi was going to arrive.
If I put you in San Francisco,
on the street corner,
you're trying to catch a taxi,
right?
And after five minutes,
all of these are going by.
You're completely stressed,
your cortisol levels are going,
and finally you get the taxi.
Now instead I sit you on the same street corner and after five minutes I say,
don't worry,
it'll be there in five minutes,
right?
You're using your phone,
your cortisol levels go down,
et cetera.
Right?
It's because of uncertainty,
right?
Which is why in London now,
they put the times on all the bus stops,
even though it's going to be an hour and a half before the bus gets there.
But no one is going to be an hour and a half.
Decreases your stress.
I had terminal five and Heathrow.
Wonderful.
Classic example.
You get off the Heathrow express,
you go on Twitter list,
there's only one place for this lift to go,
which is one floor up to departures.
So you step in,
the door is shut and now you're trapped.
Right?
Cause there's no button to tell you to go to floor one.
So the first experience that has millions and millions of dollars terminal was
stress,
right?
Because of uncertainty.
So what did they do?
They put a little button on the lift that when you touched it,
the light went on and it was connected to nothing else.
Right?
So you walked in lifts,
he had this sense that,
ah,
thank goodness,
now it goes,
it was always going to go up,
right?
It was always going to do exactly what it's doing.
But you had this sense of certainty.
Now,
familiarity,
right?
We hate uncertainty.
And again,
that's the only place we can go if we're going to be creative.
So how does the brain deal with uncertainty?
Because what's more that uncertainty and stress reduces your space of
possibility.
In fact,
here's an example of a space of possibility reducing twists.
Single dimension.
This happened.
Australia is going in to rob a bank.
This actually happened.
He hands the teller a note,
right?
And now suddenly the bank gets shutdown.
He's trapped,
he's stuck,
right?
He's locked in.
But in fact,
he's locked within a completely narrow space of possibility.
One dimension,
because he's forgotten that doors poor as well as push.
Yeah.
Right?
So he was trapped by his search space,
not by the door.
He was caught five minutes later.
Right?
Whereas it wasn't actually,
it wasn't locked.
Their door was always open,
but he was pushing against it.
Right?
Because the search space went down to a single dimension.
And that's what happens when you get stressed from uncertainty,
right?
So how can the brain,
but if the only place we can go to be creative as a step into uncertainty,
the very place that our brain evolved to avoid,
how is it that we can actually go there?
What is evolution solution towards certain certainly could is essential in order
to adopt that.
We're able to go there.
So evolution gave us a solution.
So what's the one thing that you do where you actually love uncertainty?
It's not that you tolerate it,
you actually seek it.
What's the one thing that you do?
Yeah,
play.
Play is evolution.
Solution to uncertainty.
It is why play evolved,
right?
What's more play is a way of being,
okay.
It's a way for those who study play.
It's not just running around in a playground.
It is literally a serious way of being that our brain evolved to have.
Okay.
And if we add intention to play,
we get science.
Science is nothing other than play with intention,
right?
Empiricism is inherent to the brain and how you define science and how do you
define plates so it's not likely.
It literally is play.
When we created a education program based on this,
it result in the youngest published scientist and road age eight to 10 years old
and the youngest ever Ted Speaker,
right?
Because if you add rules to play,
you have a game.
That's an experiment,
but it's rethinking what sciences,
which is not a methodology that is the craft of science,
but that's not what defines science.
Science is this way of being which celebrates uncertainty,
right?
It's encourages diversity.
It's actually how we create diversity.
The function of sciences,
in fact,
it increased uncertainty because quality of science isn't the question you ask,
right?
It's open to possibilities inherently cooperative and since intrinsically
motivated.
What does it mean to be intrinsically motivated?
Almost everything you do,
you do for reward that's different from what you do.
What is the reward for skiing
it's scheme?
The reward for play is play itself is intrinsically motivating.
And that's true for anything that is in the process of discovery.
The reward of science,
the reward of discovery is the discovery itself.
And these are actually what defines play.
And if we add intention to play,
you have science
science.
That's true.
So I'm not talking about the output of science,
but I wouldn't say science is about truth.
Science is about utility.
Evolution is not about truth.
Evolution is about what's useful about predictable,
right?
Even with our mathematics,
we have therms,
therms,
all the theorems are,
is making explicit what your assumptions are.
Given these set of assumptions,
this is what we believe to be true.
True is that this is far more predictable than that was.
So my theory of neuroscience,
for instance,
I'm looking at neurotrophic factors and brain cell growth,
right?
I'm looking empirically to see what is the most likely explanation for the data
that I've got.
I'm looking for understanding that decreases dimensionality of the space of
possibility of a search,
right?
So if I can reduce it to one variable,
verse two,
I have a better explanation,
right?
That's utility.
That's useful.
I'm making a prediction.
Is it true?
Well then we get into the semantics of what true is.
Right?
And you could argue that is truth.
To be able to predict in every single search situation is potentially true,
right?
But in terms of,
for instance,
what your brain is doing,
if your brain is the cricket or when,
uh,
when the male flies trying to mate with the female fly and is trying to predict
her trajectory,
we can mathematically model that.
Is that mathematical model actually happening inside that brain?
No.
Right.
Is genuine and behavior that is useful.
Right?
Empirically over the course of evolution,
learning and development,
right?
So science is about,
absolutely,
I'm not saying this,
this postmodern relativism atol most of my relatives,
it doesn't exist.
It did evolution from to exist.
Some things are better than others.
We just don't know what they are.
A Pri,
which is why we have empiricism,
right?
What we get from that is truth in the sense that it's highly predictable or more
predictable than the previous theory.
Okay.
And the way we do that,
but that's the process of science.
That's the scientific method,
but in order to do that,
you have to be able to ask a good question and an to asks a question.
You have to celebrate the possibility of being wrong,
of not knowing.
Right.
So my suggestion is that what underpins good science is a way of being that we
actually called play and it underpins not just science,
anything that is creative,
whereas play has no intention.
It's just simply for the sake of it.
Something like science or art actually has an intention in it,
is trying to do something right.
See what to me
earlier you had a video of people arguing about,
you know,
where it was Barack Obama born and the way you've defined science.
I would interpret that to me and it doesn't actually matter where he was born,
that where was born doesn't have an answer.
The only thing that matters is what your bias is or whether it fits your subset
of evidence.
The question of whether where he was really born doesn't really exist anywhere
in this definition,
and that's the reason why I don't buy the definition.
That question has an answer and that answer is external to me and it's external
to my biases.
And it may be true that I have bought this or that bias,
but um,
my biases have only a limited power.
My biases do not change where Barack Obama was born.
That's right there.
That fact is completely independent of my biases.
And so I,
I find this definition of science being complete cause science absolutely does
care about reality.
Yeah,
I could do it.
It doesn't necessarily care about reality.
Predicts cares about predictability.
The two can be very coincidence.
Yeah.
So I completed the process.
This,
the aim here is not to define the process science at the time.
Civic method,
which of course I apply in my own loud.
What I'm trying to suggest is that in order to apply that method,
you need to have something that comes first,
right?
You have to have a desire to ask a question.
You have to have the willingness to doubt what you think to be true already.
You have to be willing to doubt your own biases to think,
well,
maybe you,
Barack Obama was actually born here,
right?
You have to have that.
If you're going to do good science,
if you're going to apply a good scientific method,
but you could have designed a greatest experiment.
But if you have a crap question,
who cares,
right?
Because then you find a useless answer.
I want you to come up with a great answer,
but to do that,
you have to ask.
Great question.
I want you to be a great experimentalist,
but you can be the best experimentalist,
but you'll still be a crop scientist,
right?
Because you'll come up with useless answers if you're not willing to ask a
question,
especially a question that challenges your own assumptions.
And that's what science is,
is to be able to challenge your own assumptions of what you think is true.
But to do that,
your brain evolved to take you away from that place.
And one of the only places,
literally an evolution that enables you to challenge your own biases is in the
context of play.
That's the way of being that enables you to do that.
And then you apply the scientific method,
right,
of empiricism,
right?
A control one variable,
et cetera.
But having one control is,
it's like defining an artist painting based on the brush strokes where the
pigment chemistry,
all right?
The mechanism of painting is not what define whether or not it was a good piece
of art is the view.
This is incomplete in the sense that you then apply a scientific method on top
of it.
Absolutely.
And the intention of science is different from the intention of art,
but the initiation,
the desire to go forward as the thing is the argument and what's more the most
successful systems in nature.
Also the ones that play into your daughters.
So the point is you have to adopt this way of being
if you're going to ever explore the world.
Otherwise you'll be stuck in your own biases and your own assumptions.
And you'll continue to live with the idea that Barack Obama
was born now and not in the states.
Right?
So the third point is that in order to be able to ask these questions to be in a
lab,
for instance,
where questions are a good thing,
right?
You need an ecology.
It's not good enough just to be on your own necessarily.
You need an environment where asking questions is being playful is actually a
positive thing,
right?
Hence the power of the host,
the leader.
And if you ask people what defines good leadership,
you get all kinds of answers,
right?
But the only three there is associated with excessive anyone company,
which is lead by a stakes,
admit,
lead by example and mistakes and see qualities and others,
right?
These are the three that define the success of any one company and the reason is
because they actually create an environment.
Oh,
play.
The first one is lead by example.
It's space that is secure.
You can't ask questions and play outside of space.
That is trust.
This is very well known.
All right?
The second is admit mistakes.
That is space it celebrate on Sunday that mistakes are okay.
Questions are okay,
not answers,
right?
Not to say the answers are not important,
but you have to have a good question first and the third is seek.
Why isn't it as,
that's the space that celebrates,
right?
Again,
three of the parameters that are essential for a quality of play.
Okay,
so we'll finish with two examples of leadership,
right?
Here's one
sound
reassuring.
Here's the other
right notice looks up for reassurance,
right?
So the question of course is what kind of leader are you right for we can just
finish with who cares,
right at the point when I show you an illusion,
there is an illusion here.
The senior self c is actually dark,
is the same intensity as the fee that right now you're seeing an illusion,
but as soon as you know that you're seeing the Louis and your brain is holding
two mutually exclusive route is at the same time you're seeing one reality,
but you also know another reality.
Yeah,
that's an incredibly powerful thing for our brains to be able to hold,
to mute ciscos of ideas at the same time.
That is the basis for imagination.
Okay,
so this relates ultimately to conflict.
If conflict is the only place where we can actually learn.
And by definition of conflict,
I mean to enter a situation is different from what you assume to be true.
You're in conflict evolution in that sense.
You could argue conceptually as a conflicting process.
That's the only place where we can actually change the problem is we enter
conflict and usually the same way if you and I are in disagreement,
it's as if we're on different ends of the same line.
My aim is to prove that you're wrong and a shift you towards me and your aim is
to do exactly the opposite and that format of conflict we're set up to win but
not necessarily learn.
The question is how does biology do with conflict?
All right,
here's a riddle.
How can you move those two dots closer together without actually shifting the
location of the dock at all
in wards and larger circles,
right?
You increased the space,
increase the dimensionality of the space,
right?
In the case of genetics is called extra dimensional bypass,
You're complexify,
you complexify the system.
So while we might be an opposite ends of the same lines,
we can actually be at same side of a square and now gives you more directions in
which to move.
As you increase the dimensionality space you actually read,
it would be become closer and closer together.
Right now you create the possibility of learning rather than just winning.
And this is how actually nature results conflict.
Right?
By increasing dimensionality of the space.
Yeah.
So we'll finish with that idea.
Imagine in order to
do that,
you actually have to enter conflict with a question instead of an answer.
And that's the space.
That's the way of being that's required.
In order to do good science,
you enter with a question rather than with my answer.
Okay.
So I hope that's useful.
Okay,
so any questions?
Can we get,
okay,
this feels weird talking on this.
I've read an article from a mathematician that ends up questioning reality and
he says the biggest thing that stuck out to me was,
okay,
neuroscientists are asking the wrong question.
They shouldn't be asking what's happening.
They should be asking,
does the gray matter even exist if we're always constantly perceiving things
incorrectly or shared perception is kind of off.
Does the brain exist?
Does this chair even exist in this reality or are we sharing that and I don't.
I'd like to hear from a neurosciences.
Tell me a little bit about it.
Yeah.
The world exists.
The physical world exists,
right?
What we perceive of that world is not the same thing as the world itself.
I'll give you a very simple example.
The demonstrate that this has to be true,
right?
Take light.
Light is a linear spectrum from forest.
Well,
actually it's electromagnetic radiation,
which is a huge spectrum.
We are sensitive to a very small window,
which by definition we call light light is the parts of the region that we're
sensitive to.
40% of [inaudible].
It's a linear spectrum,
right?
We perceive that as a circle.
We perceive the short wavelengths to be blue and the long way breaks to be red.
Okay.
Which means that perceptually they appear more similar to each other than they
do to green,
which is in the middle.
Even though they're physically closer to green,
are perceptually more similar to each other.
It's a bit like one culo feeling a lot like a thousand kilos but very different
from 500 kilos.
So even there in our perception of color,
we don't do an isomorphic representation of light itself light.
Uh,
our perception of lights is also color.
It has four categories.
Red,
green,
blue and yellow spectrum are uniformly and continuously district changing.
There's nothing categorical about life and you have to,
it was perceptually useful to see light in terms of four categories,
possibly because of the four color map problem cartography where you need four
colors,
a minimum of four colors to color any map in order to make sure to services
don't actually have the same color,
Juha joining first African club.
So it could be useful that that's why we see four categories of color,
but it has nothing to do with category,
the category nature of spectrum.
So spectrum exists,
it's just that we don't represent them as spectrum.
We represent them in a way that was useful,
not in the way that it was accurate.
Yeah.
I was just wondering whether it has to do with genetics,
but help people stress out about,
so I
don't get nauseous on the boats in some people.
Some people do.
The question is,
does imply that I'm more tolerant to uncertainty and hence better at doing open
questions and doing science then.
Cool.
Yeah,
so it's a very good question.
I think it is true that some people actually have more tolerance for uncertainty
about others,
and it's also a really interesting question why they might be,
so now it could be genetic,
but also if you think about parenting,
so I have three kids.
My role in some sense is to create the certainty that enables them to step into
uncertainty.
Because you can step into a certain essence.
You're stepping from someplace,
right?
You can't play outside of space.
It's trusted.
So people who often can tolerate uncertainty,
it's because they have something very certain that counterbalances it.
Okay.
And so a lot of education,
a lot of weight.
It's about trying to treat that certainty.
Right?
It could be through love,
for instance,
that enables a child in this case,
to feel very warranted,
that enables them to now step into an a and be courageous and explorer.
But often kids that don't have that find it very difficult to be an uncertainty
because so much of their life is uncertain.
They're actually looking for certainly not uncertainty.
So I don't know if it's genetic.
There seems impossible.
It'd be a genetic component,
but there definitely is a difference in people,
right?
But the idea here is that we can actually help people,
other people step into uncertainty by helping to create any college that enables
them to do so.
Let's get a round of applause for both.
Thanks for coming in.